ce que c'est ok vous avez vécu le rêve
américain en juin dans des séries comme
under fort de passer fait qu'hannibal
président des excuses il ressemble à un
rêve américain parce que la vie est une
grosse maison à los angelès gros appart
à new york c'est un peu comme ça que ça
se passe
ben moi l'appartement que je vais à new
york c'était vrai avoir une boîte à
souliers comme on dit c'était un petit
appartement qui me servait de pied à
terre pendant toute ma vingtaine
c'est extraordinaire d'avoir cette
chance et dans un quartier magnifique
mais c'était loin d'être pour ce qu'ils
ont envie à beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs
qui vont souffrir
à montréal des fois les gens que je
connais pas bien me voir pour me
reconstruire mon appartement et donc
n'étaient pas en reste et luan est une
grosse cabane
moi je suis une personne très terre à
terre qui est fait juste l'expression
rêve américain a fait un petit peu pas
parce que je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
risques d'espoirs brisés là dedans et
puis de ses potes de rêver à être qui se
veut pas dans le fond entre donc moi
j'ai toujours suivi
ce que la vie m'a près comme chance
comme opportunité en travaillant très
fort mais oui voila j'ai jamais eu un
espèce de rêve roger carr et c'est tant
mieux si ça se passe pour moi du côté
des états unis mais j'ai jamais été sur
un cheval blanc français pour igor
est-ce que c'est aussi précieux que ça
en a l'air c'est un métier
extraordinaire avec des moments
magnifiques mais aussi les moments
difficiles que ce soit quand on
travaille moins que ça soit quand on
travaille fort pickeu il fait frais
depuis que les textes arrivent en
dernière minute puis bon il ya plein de
moments comme ça on se dit c'est pas
très glamour finalement meilleur des
tapis rouge pour les orties filmé et les
qu'on décroche une audition opinion sur
de joie donc c'est fait de hauts et de
beurre mais on sait jamais ce qui s'en
vient donc il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes
parfait aussi pour deux parents sont
comédiens oui j'imagine que vous en
montrer comment vivre avec les hauts et
les bas d'une carrière s'est facilement
montrer comment faire mais je les ai vus
et oui j'ai vu les moments où il ya
moins de travail j'ai vu le moment où il
ya trop de travail et donc millions il
ya une chose que j'essaie de pas faire
en ce moment vu que j'ai rien devant moi
justement c'est de m'inquiéter et passer
tout le temps que j'ai justement à être
en congés à me demander si je vais
retravailler un jour parce que tellement
de choses que je veux faire en dehors de
mon travail et j'ai le temps de les
faire en ce moment et ça serait vraiment
triste comme j'ai vu beaucoup d'acteurs
faire part si toute cette période là à
se dire hein qu'est ce qui va se passer
je suis stressé et donc moi je viens
d'avoir un bébé j'ai le temps de passer
les beaux moments avec elle alors
j'essaie d'en profiter après tout vous
est né aux états unis d'être revenu au
québec
pourquoi déchoir way des fois montréal
quand j'étais parti longtemps me
manquait terriblement la culture ma
langue
les ruelles de montréal hier y est elle
d'ailleurs
alors ouais ça toujours été pour moi une
heureux mélange d'avoir le privilège de
voyager avec mon travail mais aussi
toujours revenir au bercail moi mais
vous faites tellement arrêté dans la rue
aux états unis par contre à mon rien non
plus ici encore parce que les gens se
souviennent de mon travail quand j'étais
ado ça dans mon jeu je vieillir comme
toi t'es juste terrible de rien pour
l'heure resté pareil
oui c'est quand même des gens qui
explique mon travail encore vous qui
êtes présents quand les gens parlent de
téléséries que j'ai fait il ya 35 ans
riche
ouais ça vous attendent pas un peu ben
oui pis non parce que moi je me souviens
des séries que j'écoute à cette époque
là donc
tant mieux si les gens en les mois qui
vous est une mordue de télévision mordus
de cinéma aussi vous êtes sur le jury du
festival du nouveau cinéma
oui là qui bat son plein et vous êtes dj
aussi pour ce festival on ne vous
connaissent pas du talent de dimitri
était vraiment contente et étonné à la
fois qu'on me demande de passer j'adore
la musique j'adore danser et dans mes
pas et entre amis des fois je fais le dg
mais je n'ai jamais fait de façon
professionnelle alors j'étais très
excité qu'on me demande ça j'ai hâte
j'espère être à la hauteur quand même
avant d'en faire